féministe la balle est à monsieur franck
gilard ma question s'adresse à madame de
mini de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie
madame la ministre je souhaite vous
interroger sur les difficultés
rencontrées par les collectivités en
charge de la collecte et du traitement
des déchets avec les éco organismes dans
le cadre de la responsabilité élargie du
producteur
aujourd'hui les fabricants nationaux
doivent prendre en charge notamment
financièrement la collecte et le
traitement des déchets issus de leurs
produits ils peuvent assurer leur
responsabilité de manière individuelle
ou collective dans le cadre d'un éco
organismes ainsi la contribution des
producteurs s'élève à plus de 800
millions d'euros par an
au point de ces éco organisme agréé par
les pouvoirs publics
la montée en puissance de ces filières
depuis le milieu des années 90 a permis
des progrès très significatifs en
matière de recyclage des déchets
toutefois des difficultés surviennent
avec certains organismes à l'exemple de
celui en charge des déchets diffus
spécifiques qui a décidé unilatéralement
de suspendre la collecte sur un nombre
important de déchetterie
cet éco organismes semblent avoir oublié
que ses activités à but non lucratif
s'inscrivent dans une démarche d'intérêt
général et on a pu au service public de
gestion des déchets oublier aussi que
les collectivités locales constituent la
principale le principal canal de
collecte pour que les producteurs de
déchets diffus spécifiques puisse
assurer leurs obligations par rapport
aux produits qu'ils mettent sur le
marché
césar est colin qui représente une
interruption de prestations dans le
cadre du service public de gestion des
déchets sont illégaux au regard des
conventions de droit public liant
l'éco-organisme aux collectivités
locales
face à ces dysfonctionnements majeurs
nous vous demandons madame la ministre
de bien vouloir nous préciser les
actions qui seront engagées par votre
ministère pour rappeler à ces éco
organismes à leurs obligations et
définir un nouveau mode de
fonctionnement de cette filière
éventuellement financiers permettant aux
collectivités en charge des déchets
d'exécuter leurs missions de service
public dans des questions conditions
actionnaires si l'allemand rolex à
madame ségolène royal ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie
si monsieur le président monsieur le
député franck gilard
j'ai sous les yeux la lettre que je vous
ai adressé le 3 juin dernier sur un
sujet je vous en remercie que vous
connaissez bien
vous êtes président d'un syndicat de
traitement des déchets le 6 le seegum
vous faites un travail tout à fait
remarquable sur ce traitement là et à la
suite de votre courrier j'ai
effectivement diligenter une inspection
pour savoir pourquoi
sur cette filière à responsabilité
élargie des producteurs qui comme vous
le site est une filière récente c'est la
dernière qui a été mise en place sur
cette question majeure du recyclage des
déchets qui est au coeur de la loi de
transition énergétique
donc pour les économies d'énergie mais
aussi pour la lutte contre toutes les
formes de pollution et pour la baisse du
coût du prix aussi des matières
premières est en effet cette filière ne
fonctionne pas bien je vous rejoins sur
ce sujet parce que je pense qu'elle est
pour les gens c'est très difficile à
trier il s'agit des déchets diffus
spécifiques c'est à dire des déchets
plus dangereux et on ne retrouve que 30%
de déchets correspondant exactement à la
filière dans les bacs dans lesquelles
les gens viennent déposer ses déchets et
donc ça pose effectivement un problème
pour l'organisme qui n'est pas tenu de
traiter les déchets qui ne correspondent
pas à la filière qui sont malgré tout
déposer dans les bacs
ça pose un problème pour les
collectivités locales puisque en effet
cette filière s'est arrêté et donc le
coût du traitement retombe sur les
collectivités locales au lieu de
retomber sur les fabricants et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai demandé au
directeur général de l'éco organisme de
me justifier les raisons de la
suspension de la collecte des déchets
dans certaines collectivités
je voulais écrit cette enquête est en
cours et je vous répondrai le plus
rapidement possible pour que nous
puissions trouver une solution à ce
problème difficile que je vous remercie
d'avoir soulevé